[Music]  rown bacon lives by one motto hustle or  die in the game versus the pelicans he  chose both people asking what I was  thinking  basketball is not about thinking it's  about effort and passion and compression  sleeves oh and the outfits you wear to  games you can clearly see I was in no  position to block Davis but I was in no  position to have this haircut either but  I pulled that off  even my teammates had the sense to stay  out of the way I mean look at Beasley  using all eleven percent of his brain  here well I'm about to get browbeaten I  still replay the moment over and over in  my head when Davis hit me my soul  basically left my body what the pretty  thinking man this camera is here for me  man just just sip it all right all right  our dear  [Music]